[Music]
and tonight one of america's newest
residents prince harry is once again
bashing the usa using a recent speech at
the u.n to say this about our great
country take a listen
this has been a painful year in a
painful decade
we're living through a pandemic that
continues to ravage communities in every
corner of the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few weaponizing lies and
disinformation at the expense of the
many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
yes save us the lectures now those
condescending remarks prompted
widespread mockery for harry's complete
and total disconnect from reality
remember harry along with his wife
meghan markle are the same people they
claim they wanted privacy so why all the
hatred and disdain for the country that
he's choosing to move to
after rejecting royal life in the uk but
he's still a multi-multi-millionaire
why all the animosity and and hatred and
anger from someone that lives such a
privileged life here to answer that and
so much more i can't think of a better
guess for this a host of uncensored fox
nation host piers morgan
all right i'm a little bit
sick and tired of this putrid you know
woke rhetoric lecturing from megan and
harry now they claim they want privacy
peers but then they go on oprah for the
big oprah interview then they do a
they're doing a tv series now they're
writing a book now they're going and
blasting the us at the u.n you know what
i don't care what harry thinks and i
don't care what megan thinks and if they
don't like it here you can have them
back i will i will pay for their private
jet back
no no let's not be too hasty here sure
we've just got rid of them and this is
the only benefit to all this um
on the head i mean
thanks a lot pierce you really are pal
thanks thanks a lot
you know what it is it's revenge for
wallace simpson uh i'm afraid sean we've
waited a long time
you sent wally simpson over to destroy
our monarchy we have sent harry to go
and ruin your lives so sorry about that
we'll wait for one um look i think to be
to be serious there's such a shocking
hypocrisy isn't there about prince harry
and his wife megan and the way they go
about this these are the two that
lecture literally lecturing us again
about climate change
and how did he get to new york to make
the speech private jet how do they
always travel private jet and i've got
no problem with private jets but stop
banging on lecturing the rest of us
about how to save our carbon footprint
when you have no desire to do that
yourselves he was speaking on nelson
mandela day can you think of anybody
less qualified to talk about a struggle
of nelson mandela's kind than prince
harry whose own sense of freedom he
called this book about him came out
called finding freedom nelson mandela's
was long walked to freedom here's the
difference mandela lived in a 6x6 prison
cell for 27 years as a prisoner of
conscience then came out and became one
of the greatest iconic figures of my
entire lifetime prince harry ditched his
family he ditched his country he ditched
everything that he stood for he ditched
most of his friends
and he fled the the uk to go and live in
california with his spoiled woke wife in
an 11 million mansion for which they
preach about equality of poverty i mean
you couldn't make it up sean it's
completely ridiculous and i think he's
got to be very careful now if he's a
renegade royal and not doing any
official duty but just having his royal
caganita and he starts trashing the
american constitution and the american
people in the way that he's now doing uh
in the same way that he and his wife
trash the royal family it's not going to
end well all right don't forget pierce
morgan show uncensored on fox nation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else